hey I'm here with Patrick the generative
AI app builder showcase Booth can you
tell us a little bit about gen app
builder yeah the concept behind it is we
really want to you know take
democratization of these AI systems and
put it out there we have really two main
systems that you can do one of those is
what we refer to as Enterprise search uh
and the other one is conversational
search so Enterprise search allows users
to take their private documents or their
public uh websites things like that we
index it for them and then they can
essentially search it so think about it
like Google search results for your
private data